Mariah Carey is opening up about her
split from fiance Jing's
hacker here she is on The Ellen
DeGeneres Show Wednesday you're not
together anymore
and um not the whole freaking thing are
you happy and how are you I'm I think
I'm doing well good how are you I'm
great
no I I'm actually it's me no everything
happens for a reason things are the way
they are it's kind of difficult to talk
about at this moment so I'm just gonna
compliment you on these decorations once
again uh-huh because they are fabulous a
source previously told eg the super star
is ready to move on from the billionaire
quote she feels like she dodged a bullet
it's really for the people that that I
love like the real fans but also other
people that don't know sort of it inside
world
the elusive chanteuse is currently
promoting her daki series of Mariah's
world which will feature her flirtatious
relationship with backup dancer Bryan
Tanaka Tanaka does have a crush on her
what would I do with him you saw it he's
not leaving that easily